hallo mein name ist bekanntlich
willkommen wir heute seinen neuen videos
gerade in einem tanktop weil es einfach
fallen 30 grad in köln sind und mir mega
heiß also ja vielleicht mit kommentaren
dass ich keine muskeln aber jede von uns
hätte eingebildet meine damen und herren
ich wurde für acht und zwar von einem
anderen youtuber und ich habe ihn tief
und alles genauere daten hätten im video
nicht würde sagen wir einfach mal drauf
übrigen stelle ich euch auch am ende des
videos ein von den fünf produkten vor
der sechsten in meinen job kommen werden
also bleibt dran aber wir schauen jetzt
mal wie ein video beginnt warnung das
folgende video wurde von einem youtuber
mit wenig instagram fahrplan erstellt
und gilt somit als irrelevant
ja muss ich sagen war ein sehr
unterhaltsamer generika nämlich auf den
ins team von patrick buck hat gesagt hat
dass alle youtube an die relevanten von
youtube anhand derer instagram follower
kenn ich will gar nicht gegen marcel
schuhen oder so aber mein haus ist diese
aussage dass man die ihren rand eine
youtube auseinander instagram follower
erkennen sind nicht dumm weil also man
erkennt auch ihre der wand eines youtube
hat anhand einer youtube abonnenten das
macht doch überhaupt keinen sinn ich
zitiert nur einen kommentar der und
seinem video stand und wartet und
genauso werden sagte astronaut er hat so
viele täler in seinem schrank so wie ich
reagiere thüringen von den youtube
youtube von ihr tretet ihr ein bisschen
darüber dass er keine interviewpartner
viele news kanäle und satiriker auf
youtube einfach nicht geantwortet haben
bezüglich eines interviews und das ist
einfach der grund warum der dann quasi
mich angeschrieben hat und darüber reden
der else hat mich mal luca krank rang
kräfte angeschrieben und was soll ich
sagen luca hat zugesagt ich begrüße dich
lieber luca danke liebes mut uk ich
begrüße ich auch ich freue mich auch
noch interview ich würde sagen wir
starten da direkt einfach mal rein und
reagiert nur auf video das interview mit
mir geführt hat luca hörst du nicht wie
geht es dir heute
mittagessen zwischen den zehen alles
klar
das traurige ist das interview zu mir
tatsächlich so ablaufen könne nicht
einhalten mega selten interviews und
machen mega welten einfach irgendwie
wirken reagierte anfragen eigentlich nie
aber ja ich glaube dass von interview
mir tatsächlich so ablaufen könnte stell
dich doch einfach mal vor wer bist du
was machst du für die dich vielleicht
noch nicht da draußen kennt mein name
ist herzlich willkommen wir heute zu
einem neuen wie ihre luca gut dass das
hier ist das video von dir sondern das
wird ihn interviewt ist das weist oder
also weht schon läutet läuft darauf
hinaus dass er sich wirklich fragen
nehmen bereitet die frau und packt dann
einfach anwendungen reichen von mir von
einem anderen die welt von welchem
videobereich ich weiß nicht genau auf
welche video erst diese ausschnitte hier
benutzt hat oder so ich glaube sogar aus
dem video ich schon auf interviews
agiert habe paradies ganz neue weise
anderen verfolgen mal wieder interview
weiter vonstattengeht wir fangen jetzt
einfach angereisten einem mega short
machen geiles interview auch für die
fans da draußen richtig geilen unterhalt
und ich stelle fragen wird quatschen so
ein bisschen die reichen lieferanten
haben spart muss was sagst du dazu
obwohl ich bleibe dran ich hoffe wir der
lustige sache oder wir sagen wir fangen
ja gar mit dem interview jetzt hab ich
doch gesagt tut mir leid wie bereits
gesagt ich bin ein bisschen vergesslich
ist kann das sehr schnell sachen
vergessen wie bereits gesagt ich bin ein
bisschen vergesslich deswegen habe ich
mich doch wiederholen wie gesagt bin ich
vergesse ich dass fortan an der grund
warum ich mich gerade wiederholt wie
gesagt ein bisschen ein paar fragen
stellen und du weißt du was du dann zu
tun hat er gehe ich jetzt richtig und
sollte hier aus der frage kommen vom
tanzverbot fällen 21 ich bin vor allem
auch cool dass er das interview nicht so
vorbereitet wie stück von wegen dass er
fragen stellt sondern quasi er liebt
einfach kommentare mit fragen vorher
kleinen verlauf ist die erste frage
direkt von dem user tanzverbot fällen
kommt ich bin gespannt was der fraß und
was ich da gar wurde haare luca was
hältst du davon dass man's youtube als
den beauty teil deutschlands bezeichnet
es ist ein titel
[Musik]
jetzt sind das ganze interview heute
mitten in seinen lauf mehr lava red mit
mir über viele verschiedene themen unter
anderem über den youtube live kriegt er
hat übrigens in den letzten tagen
irgendwann ein video hochgeladen was
sehr sehr interessant war gegen andere
youtuber der irgendwie vor seinen
zuschauern oben genommen hat oder
irgendwie so könnt ihr euch gerne mal
angucken kann ich bessere bahn habe ich
mir mit marx gestern offen angeguckt auf
jeden fall ein paar fragen sein
interviewer 1 über dienen und das ganze
halt wieder der ironisch dargestellt
wird
nicht einmal weitere jetzt war mitte
november von kontakten aber ich wollte
ganze video ist auch nicht so lang
ziehen weil ich meinen wein ganzes
interview ging schon über zehn minuten
und wenn ich jetzt auch das komplette
dinge reagiert hätte wenn mein video
locker 25 minuten gegangen und er tat
und dies in deine meinung zu dem begriff
ist einen youtube-kanal denkmal wie
interviews mit youtube für die gar keine
mit ihnen interviews finden sondern in
nimwegen welche ausschnitte aus den
videos bestimmte youtuber und schneider
die für seinen antworten parteien um das
münster wurde sosa ganz schön hart
ist auch nur die wahrheit
zu starten jetzt rede ich nicht
irgendwie sein interview auf aber sehen
einfach mal selbst ich weiß nicht warum
luca luka beruhigt ich will warum man
auf eine andere frage und zwar in deinen
videos redest du manchmal irgendwie sehr
unzusammenhängend auf englisch
du bringst menschen englischen kram und
das hört sich so ein bisschen glaube ich
nach kanadischen slang es bist du
kanadier oder woher kommst du
diabetesberater ernst wenn ich auch
teuer kaufen sollte diese welt kamera
komme und banken einsendungen rhein wo
ich einen anderen video sage irgendwas
vorlese von wegen aus ganz deutschland
youtube hat hätte sein wollen ich meine
du redest wie die ganze zeit auf deutsch
gefragt nicht auf welchem land ich komme
und vor einem jahr sagt ausland du hast
du ausland du hast mir im ausland
woher denn aus
ich habe doch gar nicht ausgesagt
land ich hab ich doch gar nicht
erbrachte frau ich habe gefragt ob du
kanadier ist
ja okay du willst was sagen ich konnte
was sage ich will dich nicht unterbricht
aus deutschland moment ich mich
besonders schlaue halte und das sicher
der hitze bin ich an dieser stelle auch
anregung dass ich das fertig bin
[Musik]
du hältst dich für super lustig oder du
hältst dich für so unendlich lustig luca
jobs sorgen eines suzuki feiert sich nur
für dich nur du bist ja so intelligent
duh hält sich für so schlau ich kenne
andere freunde von dir ich bin jetzt die
namen nicht nennt max die sage nur der
lukas vielleicht doch nicht so klug wie
er mag die ganze debatte mit rein und
sagen würde wenn wir behaupten würde ich
auch gerne und egoistisch bin und auch
nicht gerade der klügste seien sie keine
bessere möglichkeit als macht einfach
mal direkt anzurufen und ihn nach seiner
meinung zu fragen wer etwa mit verfügbar
ich glaube max weicht der frage aus
damit das ganze weiterhin sind würde ich
sagen okay wir potenten mal als wäre es
passiert wie ich gesagt habe du kommst
aus kanada erwischt also immer mal
vorstellen das ganze ja quasi gerade wo
als youtuber interview sagen gestellten
normalerweise bekommen eine
interviewfrage nicht hätte haye gibt es
doch der name gekommen hätten wir leute
zu treffen er fragt kanada kommt
deswegen machst du auch nie mit anderen
leuten videos das ist der grund warum
die leute dich für egoistisch halten das
ist der grund damit niemanden pushen
muss man wenigstens vernünftige leute
gewesen
ok anscheinend ist es jetzt wohl serie
dass ich aus kanada komme
also zumindest so da und das ist auch
der grund warum ich keine andere
youtuber pushen muss youtube hat sich
and last mein freund snow tubes hat
seine machenschaften deinen freunden
gegenüber entlarven
[Musik]
sieh dich nur an ich dachte du wärst
jemand mit rückrat aber du bist mein ego
ist
ich wollte nicht nur im interview doch
jetzt kommt er seiner stelle im
interview wirklich wo er noch mal alles
zusammenfasst und noch eine sache die
wirklichen werte wichtig ihm der wir
hatten nicht nochmal uns mit eine sache
wollte ich dir immer schon sagen luca
account crafter geile wiener ich bin ein
großer fan von ihr macht so weiter
fehlen
youtube interview davon her dieses video
wurde mir ein gewendet hätte mir wurde
gesagt hey luca ich war ein videospot
guck dir das mal an und ich hab mir das
jetzt angekokelte glaube ich gesehen
jetzt gerade damit noch mal kurz zur
sache zu kommen die ich zu beginn
erwähnt habe wie ihr vielleicht wird
baumstamm zu wecken also in fast schon
einer woche ist in meinem shop fünf neue
produkte ich habe euch schon gesagt wird
wir auch schon bei twitter gepostet
holding als auch schon welche produkte
das sein werden
dieser produkte zb über schwarze locken
wenn ich also nicht für menschen
interessiert
dann könnte dieses video hier schon
beenden dann bedanke ich mich an der
feuchte zu schauen und an alle anderen
dienste sind die seite wird man eben
also das hier ist eine der fünf produkte
der verkehrte weg laufen
das ist ein los ein bisschen mit dem
ausgebrannten wagen der wird noch ein
bisschen enger gemacht um einen
zentimeter nur das musterexemplar wir
haben hier einen u3 apple darauf das ist
genau der gleiche wie bei den einfachen
und den puhdys damals schon der etwa ein
bisschen höher
das ist qualitativ sehr hochwertig also
das hat uns wieder eine menge zeit
gekommen das hinzukriegen hier an den
rechten hätten wir auch nutzen
draufstehen das ist kein 3d printer ganz
normaler druck wir fangen doch einfach
mit 3d cool an dieser stelle haben wir
halt so erlebe durchgezogen das ist dick
also es ist für den sommer vielleicht
wirklich ein bisschen zu dick aber für
seinen kühlen sommer haben es doch jeden
fall neu und die räder schon da drinnen
hier nochmal schön dass meine als logo
die größte darunter uns hier unten haben
wir auch wieder die patches fragen aber
sieht man nicht ob ihnen den stoff
sondern auch leder also aus kunstleder
[Musik]
wirklich in dem video gezeigt habe er
jedoch schon die ärmel und sohn hier
unten alles ein bisschen mehr auch
tschechen gegangen also bin ich wäre
sehr sehr cool und david auf die tage
von den bilder auf instagram ihren er
passt einfach alles zusammen da hinten
sondern schafft obsorge mit uns weil
jeder mal die in rot schwarz und der
große akku und die schwarze kamera
verschluss kasse also ja dass wir die am
erste weg launischen werden dass zum
beispiel mein lieblings produkt sogar
geht könnt ihr auch schon also die wir
auch am ersten sechs noch lanzen und ja
also ich wollte den nächsten videos
immer mal am ende so ein bisschen wir
zeigen damit ihr wisst was beim ersten
wechsel forcierten wetter geld für
auszugeben das war jetzt aber auch beim
video meine damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen getan hat will ich
nicht auf eine bewertung freuen jetzt
wird hier oben ein smiley eingeblendeter
könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren darum
die ebenfalls den shop eingeblendet wie
gesagt er weggelaufen die wachen und
hier unten ist ein anderes video
verlinkt in der beschreibung der stadt
reagiert habe